how old are you and what age range do
you date
I won't reveal my age
but I can tell you my most recent ex I
was with him on and off four years and
there was a big age difference he
I think he was 27 26 27 this year so
um yeah so I will I would date between
mid-20s and I'll go from 25 to 55. 20
wow that's a huge rain yeah enjoy you
know yeah so I I can either date you or
your dad or the other way around
okay uh I am
29 minus a week uh no 30 minus a week
apologies and I date probably
up to five years older than me Max I
think
so you won't go like if a guy's 40
that's too old
he's a fine 40 year old
um
five years okay that's a hard now wait
but you also didn't mention younger
though like you just I don't well
younger maybe Max two years younger Max
it's a tight a tight window for me
I'm 12 I'm 25. I
I wouldn't do younger anymore but Max I
would do
I think round 30s is good for me
um maybe just a bit over like
32 33
yeah oh yeah I'm 20. I would date up to
25 just because I haven't got my life
sorted yet and I don't want someone
that's that's got everything sorted out
yeah yeah
um I'm 20 and I would probably date from
like 19 to
um like a hard cap maybe like 35. okay
uh I'm 34 and I would say so my
girlfriend like she's like mid-20s so
the bottom end would be mid-20s and top
end would be around late 30s 40 late 30s
40.
I'm 29 and the bottom absolute bottom is
the 90s baby so 99
[Music]
um
um and the top end just depends on the
person
and where I am in life
um so 45 you're in she looks good I'll
be honest with you I've seen some I've
I've seen some I've seen all sorts that
look good so okay so so 50 55. there's
got to be a rough cap I'm just saying a
rough cap a rough cap yeah rough cap
um obviously JLo was an exception
for me it's a thing it's a combination
of things of course life I'm in the
Dayton space
and I don't know if she's 50 but she
looks she doesn't look like the 50s that
Society call 50 year olds then you know
I'm not gonna okay anyone that looks
good yeah okay okay but running off what
Andrew Tate said like doesn't she have
too much baggage
are we talking about dating or
commitment here well so tell me about
that's a big difference tell me both
yeah so someone you'd want to take
seriously long term and someone you go
for a short term
someone long term no
um I can't I can't start a family of a
50 year old
um
no there's some some 50 euros out there
but not for me it's not it doesn't work
for me but isn't the aim of dating like
like long-term relationships or is it
just like kind of fun depends on your
accent
I'm not I'm not I don't I don't
personally date for fun I do I do
commitments
um so if I'm looking to get married to
someone then I'm going to be thinking
about my family and who I can build
something with yeah so like you'll enjoy
being with a 50 year old like exchanging
conversation but like you wouldn't like
it wouldn't be serious you know I mean
like it would just be kind of I don't
know like understanding them meeting
them but not like it would never be a
long time yeah maybe a little kiss here
and there yeah no I feel like just just
for the purpose of the question it's
just purely for the purpose of the
question but I think if it came to a
commitment scenario
um a couple years above me at most
um but I'll probably look down as
opposed to up yeah that's just how I
view dang like I view it as something
that like I'm always seeing if you could
fit into my life like long term because
otherwise it's just gonna hurt my
feelings yeah I think that's typically
more of a female view yeah can I qualify
my answer that just get basically yeah
so like the upper end I literally just
said 40 like romantically if you look
good there's no reason why it can't even
be Beyond four eight the only reason why
I cap it at 40 because I presume you're
probably in a different stage of life
that I'm in and there might be a
lifestyle Mitch mismatch that's the only
reason but even then I could discover
that's not the case and then I'd be
willing to As Long As I you look good to
me I'm still attracted to you well good
I sorry to interrupt but um I think Ages
were irrelevant I mean there's there's a
limit to what I would go down to
see 25 is the lowest I will go
um but I think you could be this is from
a woman's point of view to men you could
be missing out from a really great woman
just because you put these restrictions
on ages and it's not all about you know
it's popping out babies it might be you
might find the woman the love of your
life for any they could be any age you
don't have to be popping Bay views out
but you could miss out
for for amazing long you know lifelong
partner with all your restrictions
that's just my personal point of view
but you kind of contradicted yourself
because you said age is irrelevant but
then you said you wouldn't go under 25.
like like what's wrong with the 24 year
old that's got his stuff together okay
yeah I said 25 but yeah if it's a 24
year old but I'm not gonna go I'm not
gonna go really low because that's not
relevant for me and I know I'm not
saying how old I am but yes I understand
I apologize for if you felt a
contradiction myself but yeah there
there is a limit but an upper limit you
could be missing out on a great man or a
great woman I agree would you do the guy
that was 90.
it could be 110 treats me well just
wants to take me out to dinner and have
some company buy me nice things but you
still have to be respectful
yeah I I I I I agreed with you to a
certain extent given I think ultimately
it comes down to your intention
so if you're if your intention is to
actually have a family I think there's a
biological clock that we can't
necessarily Overlook and you may say
like there's also yeah there are options
adoption and so forth but not every man
May necessarily want to take that route
so
my response was for an effect of my
version of a commitment where I am in my
life
I need to be with a woman that can I can
have a family with and
with my age currently speaking
the higher up I go
I guess if I want more than one child or
so forth that kind of has to be
accelerated and as a man
you know you've got a you've got to kind
of plan these things up but the planning
also takes time so you know there's a
point when I'm not sure it's different
for different women's but from what I've
learned in school
there's a point where women can't
provide families so no no I understand
that and I have a very
calm point of view when it comes to
Children I'm not going to go there now
um
I am a support person to my best friend
who is a Foster carer and I've seen the
value of fostering an adoption there are
thousands of children in this country
who would benefit from having an amazing
loving home and when you look at things
differently this is just my personal
point of view and it's no attack on
anyone here but when you look at the
children that don't actually have a home
and you've got everyone popping out
these babies I get it people say oh I
want I want blood that has to be my
blood my child but if you actually look
into it whether it's adoption or okay
fostering's different for a short time
but adoption it doesn't matter where
it's whether it's blood or not the
problem is there's a lot of problems
that come with adoption like there's a
lot of issues like if you don't get the
kid before the age of three like it's
fully developed and any issues that it
had before the age of three a lot of
times you can't stop
um and I'm not I'm not like against
adoption but I just think sometimes it
it can a lot of people aren't aware of
how hard it is when they go into it and
this is someone like I have three
adopted siblings
no no I I totally understand that and
um I have friends
um her adopted children as well but also
it depends on
the type of person you are what parent
you will be
um
the type of child there's there's so
many different variations it's just kind
of like if a guy could avoid that
headache of like like you'd have to find
find the kid hopefully it's like coming
out of a not too bad situation
um and like pain it's really expensive
too in the US I don't know how it is
here but you have to pay ten plus
thousand dollars per kid it's like why
would he go through that headache no you
don't do that here adoption goes through
obviously you know are they free here it
is it is free you go through your local
Council or adoption services and you
don't have to pay for that and over
interject I you do have to make a
certain amount of money to provide for
the child you're not allowed to just
adopt a child with no money of course of
course so the ideal you're financially
stable anyway for any child if you're
gonna get pregnant or you're gonna adopt
money is in the equation because you
have to provide a living so it's a
complete deterrent for going for older
women for guys I guess but what about
the women that like you if like scenario
that you find that your dream girl
you're in love with her and then you
find that like she can't provide a
family for you no matter how old she is
then you have to go through adoption
anyway so why is like age a hard cap I
think it's just like likelihood I mean
like geriatric pregnancy starts at 35.
um 90 90 of your eggs are gone by 30.
yeah and so it's just like if if you get
a 25 year old or 22 year old that's less
likely to happen but there's like
there's still that chance that she's
like completely infertile you know what
I mean so like I don't know in my eyes
like
it's a chance though it's like if you're
going for an older woman then it's more
likely so it's kind of it's not a waste
of time it's kind of like okay if you
pick two roads on the highway and one
has an accident every week and one and
one it's usually fine like which one are
you gonna pick yeah
um okay you too
okay
um can you repeat the question
um so how old are you so you're 20. and
what's the age range you date
um so younger
um by two years
older
three max oh wow okay three max because
Timmy I'm just doing long term so yeah
okay
um I'm 28
um if I'm taking it serious
uh looking for something long term then
my market would be 21 to 32.
if I'm just outside in the field having
fun then
20 to 50. as many of you know I was just
banned on
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible